تفاصيل مؤامره الاغتيال الملكه اليزابيث
الثانيه يكشف عنها مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي الامريكي الاف بياي بعد نحفي
تسعه اشهر على رحيلها الاذبيعي كشف ان
المؤامره قادها الجيش الجمهوري الايرلندي
خلال زياره الملكه للولايات المتحده عام
1983 وفي هذا التاريخ وشرط انطلقت معلومات
استخباراتيه تفيد بان الملكه اليزابيث قد
تكون مستهدفه من قبل احد المتعاطفين مع
الجيش الجمهوري ايرلندي الذي اراد
الانتقام لمقتل ابنته في ايرلندا الشماليه
وبحسب سجلات الاغبياء فان هذا الرجل كان
لديه سيناريوهان لمحاولته اذا الملكه
الاول عن طريق اسقاط جسم من جسر البوابه
الذهبيه على يخت بريطانيا الملكي اثناء
ابحاره وثاني عبر محاولته قبل الملكه
عندما تزور حديقه الوطنيه في كاليفورنيا
وعلى اثر هذه التهديدات اغلقت الخدمه
السريه الممر ات على جسر البوابه الذهبيه
مع اقتراب اليخت ومن غير الواضح ما هي
الاجراءات التي تم اتخاذها في وسامتي لكن
الزياره مضت قدما ولم ينشر الاف بياي اي
تفاصيل عن اي اعتقالات نفذها